Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man and venom
video Marvel and Sony just confirmed
some details on a new spider-man venom
to crossover character and crossovers
that go beyond that and because the
venom 2 producers are talking about
doing even more versions of the
symbiotes beyond venom and carnage in
the comics will break down the most
powerful versions of the symbiote and
explain the progression of symbiotes
beyond venom and carnage which ones came
after a carnage so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the easter-egg videos we'll do a new
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
which other symbiotes do you want them
to do in the movies so starting with
number 5 if you didn't see it recently
Marvel and Sony we're talking about the
future of the spider-man and venom
characters through spider-man 3 in venom
2 because of the virus delays both
movies are coming out next year
venom 2 is coming out in June and then
spider-man 3 is coming out in November
so they're way closer together than they
were before the Morbius movie which is
still a spider-man venom spin-off is
coming up before venom 2 as well as
much as Tom Hollands spider-man himself
as the main crossover character the
other biggest one that you've all
probably theorized or learned about is
actually J jonah Jameson himself from
the Daily Bugle Ned we've already seen
enough Morbius trailer Easter eggs to
know that JJ Jameson is appearing in
that movie in some way we even got some
details about what that will look like
and recently JK Simmons himself did an
interview confirming what's going on
with his new contract that he signed
with Marvel and Sony for the spider-man
movies he said it was for multiple films
and he's got a couple more guaranteed
appearances on it as of the end of
spider-man far from home so for he said
the contract was technically with Sony
but that it also covered the MCU marvel
spider-man movies not other MCU movies
just the spider-man movies both Marvel
and Sony which includes all the venom
stuff the Morbius any other spider-man
spin-offs that Sony wants to do so this
just confirms more J jonah Jameson for
venom 2 in spider-man 3 the way he spoke
about his contract is that they could do
anything they wanted to with his
character in those upcoming movies it
wasn't that he was supposed to get a ton
of scenes or be a huge part of the story
but based on what we know about the
Morbius movie the way they're using him
in that is very similar to the way they
used him in spider-man far from home and
it's sort of a template for the other
movie
as well we'll call it the Spider Man ps4
method of J jonah Jameson it feels
like everyone on the planet played that
video game at some point but if you
didn't for some reason during the game
they had broadcasts of JJ yelling about
how terrible spider-man was while you
were web slinging around New York City
completing missions this is just a fax
with J jonah Jameson where listeners
like you discuss the issues affecting
our city with pulitzer prize-winning
two-time two time Pulitzer Prize winning
former publisher of The Daily Bugle blow
the book and and as always if order
mr. Jameson's books Spider Man threat or
menace within 24 hours of our broadcast
you'll get an autographed copy at no
extra charge no personalizations
don't ask it welcome to just the facts
with J jonah Jameson alerting you to
the threats you don't even know about
like you see all these bus ads asking
about spider-man where's spider-man
what's going on people calling him a
murderer with graffiti on the walls
Morbius is walking by so spider-man and
Daily Bugle J jonah Jameson stuff all
over the place so I would just expect
the same treatment for J jonah Jameson
in the Morbius movie in venom 2 and in
spider-man 3 and because of course
there's going to be more spider-man solo
movies a big spider-man fan and
crossover movie a sinister six movie
that Sony has been teasing for a while
now it's pretty safe to assume that
they're going to try and get JK Simmons to
come back for more little cameos and
some are most of those movies too
especially the biggest ones he's kind of
become the Nick Fury style character of
the larger spider-man spider verse and
venom verse movies between Marvel and
Sony the one guy that connects all the
movies outside of the hero character
Peter Parker spider-man but number three
because the venom and spider-man people
are talking about doing more symbiotes
the big symbiotes way beyond venom and
carnage what are the next ones they
would do if they're going through the
comics in chronological order what came
after carnage and then after that what
are the most powerful versions of the
symbiote
one of I think our great hopes for
future films is other articulations of
denim sweater carnage we're talking
about the toxin symbiote toxin is
actually the spawn of the carnage
symbiote the same way that venom spawn
carnage
so toxin is kind of like Venom's
grandson but he bonded with a police
officer named Patrick Mulligan and
became a hero he was actually one of the
first symbiotes the Spider Man
considered an ally becoming a bit of a
mentee too spider-man then after the
toxin symbiote there was the anti-venom
symbiote and a lot of people wondering
if they're going to do anti-venom at some
point he was a hybrid symbiote that was
created accidentally in Eddie Brock when
the codex's of the Venom symbiote
combined with Eddie Brock's body in
mystical energies from mr. negative
for the most part it as crazy healing
abilities and as the name implies
anti-venom it has a lot of anti symbiote
powers for fighting other symbiotes
what's probably going to happen after
they do venom and carnage fighting each
other during the venom 2 movie is that
they'll go for their big spider-man
venom crossover in a separate movie then
after the big spider-man venom team-up
movie they go back to the venom solo
movies that's when they would probably
try to do another iteration of the Venom
symbiote like doing the toxin character
or the anti-venom character you have to
consider that they're introducing a ton
of other spin-off characters like the
Morbius character so eventually Sony is
going to try and crossover all of its
crossover characters like you have the
black cat movie that they're talking
about doing the silver and black movie
with silver sable that'll all be going
on while they're also trying to
introduce other iterations of the Venom
symbiote so obviously it's going to take a
while to get through all the different
venom symbiotes number two here's where
we get to the S Tier symbiotes talking
about venom tier list starting with null
the god of the symbiotes this is a
relatively recent addition to the Canon
to know was the God who existed in the
void before the Big Bang of the Marvel
Universe after the most recent version
of the universe came into existence
eternity creates the Celestials you kind
of know how galactic history plays out
the Celestials start gardening the
universe the rise of humanity the modern
marvel universe and all the characters
that we know in present day but right up
to the Big Bang the Celestials are
created know despises the universe
itself because it's sort of this
invasion on his void his nothingness so
he wants to return the universe to his
nothingness
the Celestials with a piece of himself
that he uses to create a sword
the necro sword aka the primal symbiote
also called the all-black that was
wielded by Gor the god butcher in the
Thor comics he uses that to cut the head
off of one of the Celestials supposedly
that celestial was nowhere from the
guardians of the galaxy movie like
nowhere isn't the name of the celestial
that's just the place that they call it
and it's the head of a dead celestial
from the beginning of the universe then
no the god of the symbiotes goes on to
create the actual symbiotes the Clint
our race itself so the cynthia's are
basically pieces of him then even though
there are other uber powered up versions
of carnage like carnage wielding the
primal symbiote in Eddie Brock's new son
that they just introduced in the comics
who's a human symbiote hybrid that can
actually forcibly control other
symbiotes against their will
there was even a venom eyes version of
the Hulk which was pretty cool to look
at I don't know that they would ever get
to know in the movies that would
actually be a really cool story that
would be their version of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers end game but
I'm kind of hoping that instead of that
they actually make a beeline for
live-action spider-man into the spider
verse just because it feels like it's a
little bit more believable that they
could pull that off than a big Knoll
universe spanning story plus if they do
live-action spider-verse
is a really good excuse to bring back
Tobey Maguire spider-man and Andrew
Garfield spider-man on screen with Tom
Hollands spider-man number one the
actual most powerful version of the
symbiote is now cosmic venom from venom
the end this is the most crazy Opie
version of venom that you've ever heard
of before this is a version of venom
that over time learned how to go full
ego the Living Planet terraforming the
entire universe venom izing everything
even terraforming entire planets with
symbiotes it gains several God level
powers and time-travel powers through
symbiosis and eventually is able to
completely reboot the entire Marvel
Universe because it has a template for
every living thing that ever existed so
it effectively creates a backup for all
of existence across space and time and
then just completely recreates it there
is probably no way they would ever do
something that big in the live-action
movies with the venom character but it
would make a really really badass Marvel
what if episode if they ever wanted to
animate it
these are really good news recently that
you probably saw in real life is that
most every movie including the Marvel
movies the Sony movies everything is
going back into production around
mid-july that's when everything is going to
start filming again so with as much as
we've kind of been waiting for a lot of
new content to drop the second half of
the year is going to have a lot more stuff
coming especially the big marvel of
Disney Plus series I just did a video
about all the Marvel Disney Plus series
so I'll link that at the end of this but
we have Mandalorian season 2 we have the
Marvel Wandavision series we have
Avengers Falcon and Winter Soldier all
that stuff is going to be coming up the
second half of the year so what will
happen is as we get more details as they
start filming again and dropping teasers
and trailers of course we'll do videos
for all that stuff but leave all your
big video requests and big questions in
the comments below
everyone click here for my new venom 2
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for my new Wandavision trailer and
update on all the Marvel of Disney Plus
series thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys tonight!